all I wanted things to be able to have
the kind of physical structure that
could dunk a basketball that would be
pretty cool jump jumping was always my I
want just two inches longer to it if I
had two inches more yeah well cuz I can
jump okay I just need two more inches
but now there's like there's these you
go on YouTube there's like drills where
people teach themselves how to jump
there's guys that have like small
verticals yeah they train and they get
bigger verticals yeah - am I too busy
for that for me it's like learning how
to do a backflip I'd like to do that and
I could I don't I'm too busy you don't
need to do a backflip though no there's
not one time in your life when someone
says do a backflip and we won't right I
just kill you I want to have some arrow
where I call it air air awareness I want
to be an aerial I want to be an aerial
athlete I mean an aerialist I want to be
an aerialist you want to be up in the
air doing stuff sometimes in case I got
out you could go pro at any sport would
it have been what would it at hardcore
not a pro sport if I could go pro if I
had my druthers yeah the sport I love
yes
tennis boxing boxing boxing tennis just
seems such a boring I would love to be
able to I really love boxing so I think
if I come to it at a young age two
things would have happened one I would
have become obsessed and given myself
brain damage trying to become good or
the other is I would have gotten hit
hard enough so I stopped
so usually put you out well you can you
can you can box it's really fun and then
you can take a shot and I've been
knocked out how's your chin it's I have
no idea
not good I've been knocked out plenty
when I say plenty I probably knocked out
I knocked out five times when I was in
Taekwondo you definitely got brain
damage yeah when I was when I was when I
was when I detected you get caught with
the wheel kick he caught with a
roundhouse whatever was you'd have a
cold one day to spar you wouldn't be
thinking and you turn somebody kick in
the face whatever the day would just
happen never had it happen in a
tournament but boxing and and I came
back oh you would always be a little shy
I was being a little gun-shy when you
dispare would ruin you for six months
sometimes six months yeah because when
you get hit in the head for me for me
I hated it some guys get hit in the head
in there like they come back more me I
wanted to cry literally would want to
cry
I would not be alright I just not be
alright because I'd be so vulnerable and
for six months I'd be gun-shy and my
sparring would suck boxing I've not
gotten there because I spar guys who are
not good ice bar guys who are and we're
moving around and it's it's it's moving
around what's the age and weight are
they your everybody's younger than me
everybody's younger everybody whoop your
ass no people don't whup your ass you
know but but about in a street fight do
you think you'd be good in a street
fight I don't know see that's all I'm
fighting yeah I think about that you're
probably better at me at boxing but I
think I might but I was a wrestler but I
think I might murder you want a street
fight well I was a wrestler but I'd it's
all up I'm staying up I'll have you ever
had any have you ever have you ever done
any stand-up comedy fighting I've been
doing it for a while if you haven't
black bum Taekwondo and I box a lot I
know but I just want to fight you in the
street yeah I'll kill you okay and I
don't like the way you're looking at me
right now cuz I'm gonna do it your hand
now you got some long hands but I'm
gonna get under your [ __ ] whatever
you throw I'm gonna dip and I'm gonna be
close to you on either side and then I'm
gonna work your goddamn body okay you
know what though well I just hug we're
gonna we're gonna loop this clip at the
hospital or the doctor that three fights
are a whole different game all I learned
was street fighting as a kid that's all
I knew yeah you seem like a you have
some we are comic and you have your
athletic so you have some anger I just
got made fun of when I was a kid so I
would just punch people these are true
stories I got kicked out of kindergarten
for fighting you get your you're Italian
you're from Chicago [ __ ] yeah anger
you'll fight oh man I was so quick Oh
shoes you of all the comments they're a
lot of congress's you know if I had to
go fight if I was in a bar and they said
I mean really one of the first guys I'm
gonna call who's the last guy you would
call Bobby Lee yeah but I bet if he
shows his dick they clear out nobody go
on but but I love Bobby but there most
comics are not gonna get your back and
they're also not gonna go fight Bobby's
the reason that I'm at the Comedy Store
yeah but then again you know all this
stuff comes from my insecurity and
self-loathing with my neighbor goes man
you're so disciplined you work out I go
I'm not disciplined I'm just insecure
and I don't like myself said you're
secure enough to have a belly yeah I am
not secure enough at 51 I still have to
go spar in case something happens
that's who you're dealing with yeah I
say I stay in shape I stay in shape
because I can't be I can't be sad and
fat that's right I can be sad and in
shape yeah I don't get sad by the way I
definitely get say I'm lucky that way I
have your shirt on too I said so I'm
dumb dumb I'm a dumb I don't think
deeply I can take a nap and I'm fine
no matter what happens I can never take
a nap Jack if I take a nap I'm reeling
if I'm sleeping if I'm sleeping well
mm-hmm and I'm working out very little
gets me down what's your butcher what is
your workout routine are you every day
so I I do a combination of CrossFit and
I box a lot now especially now I don't
like CrossFit
I don't either and my heart races every
time I have to go train with my buddy
Nick who who I train now a deuce which
is an open garage on Lincoln and
everyone can see you everybody's
stronger than me everybody's tougher
than me everybody's a real crossfitter
and then there's the [ __ ] the actor
the sweetie who wears a hat so the Sun
doesn't hit his face I wear one of them
long one of those golf has a golf like
it huh
yeah I'm not what do you weigh I'm 170
tops right now yeah yeah yeah yeah watch
your tongue oh good what's gonna happen
what are you gonna do use some of that
boxing you've been doing
[Laughter]